you've got an Emmy for your performance
and everybody loves rain right this man
this meant a long time Ray Romano is
about as level-headed and immune to
compliments as anyone you can imagine in
the business especially the comedy
business but I'm wondering if when you
got the Emmy for for Everybody Loves
Raymond for your performance did that a
little bit go to your head just a little
bit just a little bit and he's doing
your oats I don't know what that is but
I wasn't doing that no no I a matter of
fact this was a while ago by the way
what I want that and I remember the day
after I was in a movie theater in Malibu
and Sandler was was sitting next to me
and I'm saying we just happens and I
kind of know him I don't know him that
well but we remember and he said
congratulations and the movie ended and
we went out and and these kids most of
them were teenagers and swarmin coming
around for degraaf's for pictures and
autographs for him all for him
they just surrounded him and it humbled
me you know Here I am with the a me III
didn't have the Emmy with me but and I
so I didn't even get a chance to say
goodbye to him you know and I'm walking
away I'm like alright that's a little
humble pie right there and I walk away
and then as I get a few feet away I hear
mr. Romano mr. Romano right sir okay
whatever and he comes running home
because from and he has his phone he
goes could you talk to my grandmother
[Laughter]
but I'll take it